[Music]
alright so we just got done seeing the
new the mule yeah which was new Clint
Eastwood flick about I would call it a
crime drama adventure about an old guy
in his 90s it becomes a mule for the
Mexican drug cartel and a little
adventure that he has yeah it's like a
little adventure what happens to him and
I tell you what I think this is one of
the first time Jen and I were the
youngest people in the theater yeah it's
well it's Tuesday and Tuesday is $5
ticket do so it's always more people in
here on Tuesday
but wow it was like super packed and it
was just a sea of grey just a seal and
notice of dirty man they're throwing
popcorn everywhere and when they took
him forever the filter out and after
they level of theater I'm looking around
us like children I mean I just had shits
like a prawn everywhere they come in
there sweep it up and I'm going you poor
people yeah okay it was a good movie I
think had a UH I really liked it up
until the very end I think the end kind
of had a anti-climactic
and that was soothing it didn't really
go up didn't really go out with a bang
but the rest of the movie I really liked
it I thought was well directed the
acting is fantastic and all the
characters are really good in it it just
didn't it kind of goes out with a
whimper but you know what something
about this movie that I wasn't expecting
because we've been seeing the trailers I
said oh it's pretty good we should grow
while we see that and it's like there's
a lot more humor in it than I was
expecting
um you know what I mean it was just kind
of like cuz Clint Eastwood I mean he
looks more and more like a mummy like a
scarecrow this but yeah it's like super
scary look that's the character this is
all the [ __ ] but yeah but like it's kind
of like um grouchy old coot the movie
yeah but like in like in an entertain
kind of way because like he doesn't know
how to do anything like he doesn't know
what a taxi this if he's like I have to
call the internet and surely the
highlight is the highlight of this movie
is his interaction with the drug cartel
yeah the guy like that the guys from the
drug cartels I mean they're portrayed I
think realistically I mean they're
badasses but they're also just guys yeah
they do funny [ __ ] it's just it's like
it's just funny because you can see how
this would happen because I mean some
dudes like some dude who's like oldest
[ __ ] and like was a drug mule it's like
they would never suspect you know I
guess they didn't really talk his way
out yeah because he's just like yeah and
he did like some yeah it was it was it
was a funny movie I think my oh my only
criticism of the thing was that it goes
out with a whimper instead of going out
with a bang I think I had I done this
movie I think got a rip a little
stronger ending for I would have put a
shootout in or something but uh yeah I'd
recommend it it's good movie yeah
[Music]
you
okay so we just got done watching into
the spider-verse
which is the origin story for Miles
Morales which was the comic for the
comic book version of the new spider-man
now if you're up on what's going on with
Marvel the movies are doing fine the
Netflix series is doing really well but
the comic books are just being basically
rejected by the market I mean the
writing is supposed to be rock bottom
and the heart isn't that good and they
just can't sell them they're pushing
them on comic book stores and the comic
book stores can't move them so because
of that I actually had very low
expectations for this when I was just
trying to get it down the way but in the
movie you have Miles Morales you also
have the original spider-man of what
happens to him and then all these other
Spiderman to come through a dimensional
door that was built by kingpin and Doc
Octopus
so you're kind of for the first time to
kind of come and face to face with these
spider-man reboot characters in this
film and I'd have to say that they were
well-written I think the characters were
well-written they're they're evidently
much better written and what they are in
the comic books because I found the
Miles Morales character to actually the
kind of you know okay and I thought the
the visuals of the movie were really
good what do you think actually I don't
usually care about seeing stuff in 3d
but I'm actually really glad that we saw
those men look good because this is one
of the coolest looking bees that I've
ever seen and I really liked I really
liked they kind of mixed up the Styles a
little bit yeah if you saw that you
probably saw the trailer
you know so you know that some of the
alternate universe spider people like
ones like an or spider-man yeah yeah and
ones like a Porky Pig 10 minutes and
then anime she's in a robot like a mecha
and everything so so they almost have
like a little bit it's not like really
jarring but they have like the animation
is slightly different depends on what
universe is a universe thing what the
house happens some of the stuff looks
very comic II some of it looks very
realistic like there were some times was
I blame and I'm looking at film or
mother it just depends yeah like a lot
of it had like a really cool like that
you know the dot matrix kind of oh yeah
he's you know like the old school I give
it I gave the animation a big thumbs up
I mean it's a gorgeous it's a gorgeous
course my only gripe about the animation
is that some in some of the action
scenes the framerate was not very slow
so it looked very choppy yeah it's very
they try to the fight thing yeah really
quickly they try and they tried to make
it look like it was old-fashioned
animation where there weren't many
frames to the motion and it just it
happened real fast and you didn't really
see much detail which they did that on
purpose they that was what they chose to
do and I kind of disagreed with it
because in other sequences the action
was nice and smooth and you could tell
what happened so I think they just need
to pick that nice and smooth
you're gonna mean frame rate for the
action scenes I liked him
now what ended up happening know is that
when you come into it when you're seeing
the other spider-man reboots I actually
kind of felt there were two of them that
were more interesting than the pasta
Morales characters and that was the film
noir spider-man which that was Nicolas
Cage doing yeah I'd just see a movie
just with that character you should
actually do that they should do it off
shoot and spider-gwen I like spider-man
I feel like spider-ham I would see a
whole yeah yeah
but a little Porky Pig but after seeing
this one I kind of favor like I really
don't care too much about what would
happen like Morales that was a good
story yeah but I don't need any more of
it I don't really need any more him I'd
actually would like to see more of the
noir spider-man in the 30 like they
probably would because I've said this is
the Miles Morales it's like his origin
story is also like a coming-of-age story
of him like you know finding his
confidence and finding his way in life
and that's mostly what the story focuses
on so it actually does really have an
emotional core and stuff yeah but yeah
it's like now that he's kind of like in
his universe you know he later man I
probably feel like they should probably
like branch out into different movies
about some of the other because I would
totally like I said I would totally
watch maybe on some of the other spider
people yeah really cool I would favor
the noir spider-man and spider went yeah
I actually thought Spiderman was chronic
kind of cool a female version of
spider-man in a parallel universe she
kind of had the ballerina thing going
with issues yeah I thought that was a I
thought that was kind of a cool
character but the black and white you
know arse
you know his dialogue and everything is
like very Indiana Jones very cool
different private dick you know and that
would make a really good movie and they
should do it all yeah but like I said
this was actually it's a little bit
different than what I was expecting like
I said it actually had you know a
character driven story and stuff you
know there was a kind of action
sequences and really cool visuals and
stuff too but it actually had you know a
character arc yeah I know a lot of
emotional investment between the
characters so I thought that was kind of
cool and it's like like I said this was
actually one of the coolest looking
yeah these dive members and I would
recommend seeing in 3d and oh yeah
3d and they've really made sense really
it really does make sense seeing this
ends really cool again yeah and a lot of
the gripes of the
of the new Marvel comic books is that
it's bad writing the people that are
writing are not really trained writers
they don't really come from the
backgrounds that you need because you
know comic books really would basically
war propaganda you know that's what gi's
read during the world wars and there was
a lot of warrior virtue in the writing
and that's evidently lacking in the
comic book but it's not lacking in this
I thought it had good heroic virtues
didn't you say I was and I think the
whole message of the movie is that like
you know you have to find your own
heroism yeah yeah and then basically
like you've been willing to sacrifice
yourself yeah yeah it's like this was a
little bit different than I was
what is it was expecting but it actually
turned out much better much better than
X better than I expected yeah okay guys
okay just got done seeing vox lux
this one had natalie portman in it and
what's his name Jude Law yeah and I
think they produced both of them
produced this movie and it's about about
a pop star
and I liked it it had touches of
brilliance to the movie it drove about
half of the audience out of it the first
[ __ ] said because they were expecting
kind of this real be that bit candy pop
is this nothing like that
it's like it's like pretty hardcore yeah
well like a very I mean if you just read
like a like a brief plot synopsis it's
like a tragedy becomes a pop star later
on yeah you will not be expecting that
now the there's a deeper analysis to
this movie I didn't really like the
ending I thought the movie was going
along pretty good there was a certain
ending I was expecting and it didn't
deliver on that and yeah I don't want to
really spoil all but yet it doesn't end
we expect but you keep expecting it to
and it never happens it kind of gives
you a stomachache yeah it to happen ever
really happens that I would say the
deeper meaning of the movie is that the
world is a very vapid and shallow place
and pop music is even more vapid and
more shallow and what's really going on
behind the scenes is pretty bad and that
pop music is a performance art very much
like terrorism okay but terrorism is a
performance art that actually kills you
yeah and that it it looks like the world
that we live in today pop music is
slowly being replaced with terrorism
that terrorism is a better form of it
that's the bold stance that this movie
yeah so you don't go in exactly it's
like some like happy little musical
about because this stuff I you saw the
trailer I didn't see that
but I think the trailer mostly just
focus on like the performance stuff like
with her in the costumes and everything
that's really only the last 10 15
minutes of the movie up to that it's
totally not what yeah and it rolls the
[ __ ] out of you this movies hilarious in
certain spots and it's Natalie Portman
is so good and that and the tone is so
serious that the audience doesn't know
it's troll on them I'm just [ __ ] this
we were laughing well we were laughing
it was spotty I loved very very dry here
she's so funny like is the you know the
kind of the first probably have for the
movie almost is her as a teenager like
in her you know early days so it's a
different actress like playing her as a
14 year old but when she comes in like
as an adult and she starts you know
she's her character is bright poop
Staten Island and she's very just a very
grisly rock-and-roll chick yes and she
just says she's funny no filter and just
like in making political statements that
are just insane and you go yeah that's
the kind of [ __ ] celebrities say weird
[ __ ] yeah right and we were sitting
there just like it laughs and no it's
the middle of the afternoon it's a
Thursday it's like it's not it didn't
get much I didn't even hear about it
until it's like pop so yeah kids I think
they were expecting their 27 else and
then they [ __ ] ran out of there in
about ten minutes it's so funny because
what they're creating today as children
reminded me so much of those old
Baptists that we [ __ ] ran into oh my
god this is this is sin we have to get
out of here it triggered the [ __ ] out of
them I just roll with it was like okay
we're they they ran out and I love when
you go into a movie like not like maybe
even expecting one thing and like it
totally doesn't mean different so I like
that so it's like really surprising now
this is gonna be a really polarizing
movie like I said something
it's an indie flick it's a very indie
flick you know but I really like the
weirdest [ __ ] but I really really made
this with their money and they just
basically saying [ __ ] you they got
something they're gonna say they're
trolling you yeah well basically one of
the big themes of the movie is that that
biz that in in pop culture just even
when it comes to television a big part
of the sales to the big part of the
sales strategy depends on you being
stupid because you [ __ ] bought this
[ __ ] and that's they depend on you being
stupid and that's really what this movie
yeah yeah yeah I really like this I mean
kudos to Natalie Portman's performances
yeah but funny and like kind of dark
yeah it's hard to explain I don't even
know what genre I would call this yeah
this is slice of life I guess it's just
like a terrorism yeah that's a really
weird yeah and not I proved that but I
proved that I really like there's okay
yeah I like it I was I was I was
informed
[Music]